oh I'm getting the inside dope here at
sxm Sirius radio and uh talking to Morel
now Morel how long have you been with
Sirius uh almost 15 years wow okay you
kind of run all the comedy stuff here at
SiriusXM hello
program a lot of the channels let me ask
you something what channels are these
comedians on so we have a lot of Comedy
channels but what numbers start at let's
see uh 95 night wait 95 94 95 96 yeah
what are you talking about I'm at 106.
106. I've been in this business forever
how did you how do these people get such
young numbers there's uh some people
that are like named Kevin Hart and Kevin
Hart he does too many ads Kevin Hart
finishes one ad so remember get the
platinum card and then the next ad is
like do you have trouble on the toilet
and it's Kevin Hart again he's a friend
of mine I was talking to him on the
phone the other day the call got
interrupted four times because he did
ads
it's impossible
so which which channel is he on I think
it's 96 yeah because that he's on 96
Kevin Hart's on 96.
Jeff and Larry's comedy Roundup is on
97. Jeff and Larry's comedy Roundup what
is comedy cattle what is that
yeah
comedy Roundup pretty much do you
realize that there are channels far
below me on the dial that are just there
as discussions yeah they're there for
the emergency broadcast system yes and I
can't get those channels literally you
turn on channel 55 and it's
then 56 welcome to Tommy rounder then
57.
who's programming this [ __ ] who's making
these decisions you've got a Porsche
here and you've got a bunch of Toyota
tercels doing donuts in a shitty parking
lot on 55 56 57 58. why have they put me
they always do this to the Irish they
push us it is they push us way out
Brian is it oh you're more than welcome
to stay there's a room for you
in the back
I'll keep walking way in the back
there's a little space for you yes climb
underneath not on the bed mind you get
underneath it might be a tater there for
you it's ridiculous
I'm sorry I mean you look brokenhearted
about the whole thing
were you personally when you heard that
I was at 106 were you a little surprised
at the high number yeah I actually I
couldn't believe that they did that to
you because
um you you're such a great person and a
wonderful comedian and I don't know why
they would do that I'm surprised that
they even kept the rest of the comedy
channels they should have just removed
them just and kept yours
that's fantastic yeah that is the most
brutally honest answer you could have
given it's very why are there other
comedy channels I don't know we can also
I mean I love Kevin Hart but he's I
think he's now more of a Hitler she's a
pitch man yes and so and I love him but
he makes 75 movies a year and he makes
uh well over 12 000 commercials and all
the commercials I don't know what he's
selling it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter so even Kevin doesn't know what
he's selling they'll often take one
credit card out and put in a completely
competing credit card in his hand and
he's like next card and they put the
next card in next card sometimes they'll
just put a cat in there you want this
cat get this cat now they just keep
switching things out on him that's how
he can do so many of them yeah but he's
man
he figured it out that guy has got bank
that's means he's got a lot of money is
that what I mean yeah sorry I was gonna
ask I come from the streets yeah is that
where and I'm told that he has Bank
uh what is your your name is Morel my
name is maral try it one more time try
it again I think you got it yeah what
marao
um what kind of name is that it's an
Armenian name you're Armenian
right
that's all I got after that it's just
Kevorkian Cher and so you're aware of my
assistant Sonam Obsession yes I am very
aware of her are you a fan of Sonos I am
a bigger fan of hers than most people uh
that must say bigger fan of Sonos
that's what I meant to say yes I'm a
bigger fan of Zona than you you know
sona's gonna get a channel
51. she's going to be at yeah Sona my
assistant who does [ __ ] doesn't do
anything for me is going to be Channel
51 and I'm up at 106.
and because you're behind the scenes I'm
gonna do it for her you Armenian people
all help each other don't you we do it's
a cabal it's a conspiracy absolutely
right yeah and I'm gonna still have most
of Glendale California we'll be in the
50s and 40s
I know what you're up to I know what
you're up to I love Sona Sona is great
she's fantastic she's wonderful I can't
wait to meet her well you're meeting me
so oh well I'm close it's like two
degrees right so it's exciting
[Laughter]
okay I was gonna ask her if she could
sign my book and then I thought maybe
I'd ask you but then I I didn't know if
you'd be comfortable signing a book
someone else wrote that wasn't you
because I'm such a big fan of her
no I'm not going to sign sona's book for
you all right you can get sewn in a sign
sona's book for you okay what is your
last name it's always with an iin at the
end right yeah yeah Kardashians yeah
they're calf they're not real what
they're not real didn't they do a trip
where they went to our church
Armenian yeah and I think they didn't
even land I think they they were in they
were in six they were in six different
private planes yes and they circled and
they they were drinking Moet champagne
and at one point they were uh asked to
just look out the window two of them did
the others were
busy watching a movie I really
appreciate you taking uh your show and
sauna to Armenia and that was huge
because
showing the world that as someone that's
not Armenian and watching that like
everyone appreciated that and learning
about them that's nice so okay that was
pretty cool did that make you like me
more than Sona
um for a minute I'd a little bit yes
well I think it made me
um enjoy enjoy watching your other shows
more okay
are you a fan of my comedy yes I mean
you're you're I do I do listen to your
podcast and I don't you know what on
YouTube okay if you say any more of my
feelings are gonna get hurt because
you're gonna say something like I like
the early stuff and then there's a whole
period in the middle I didn't like but
then I think you're getting better again
but I worry about your age
that sounds like exactly what you would
say
um no maybe a little bit all right well
I've learned a lot you largely produce
comedy you don't enjoy correct
um on channels that are far lower than
mine yep
um you are working with other people in
The Armenian Community to destroy me and
take me down and promote my assistance
yeah it's good gig I get to meet you
today and talk to you about yeah you got
one step closer to Sona your dream come
true this is my whole plan oh